okay a couple more debate related
stories and then we're going to move on
to other things number one Donald Trump
really exposed during yesterday's debate
that he fundamentally lacks knowledge
not just about many of the issues that
have come up regularly so for example
how trade deals work or how most things
work but even about issues that are just
so basic that it's really shocking that
Donald Trump is the Republican nominee
here's an example okay here's a comment
Trump made about the overturning of roe
v-- wade sort of in the context of
Supreme Court justice selection take a
look but I'm asking you specifically
would you like they overturned it it'll
go back to the states but what I'm
asking you sir is do you want to see the
court overturn you've just said you want
to see the court protect the Second
Amendment
do you want to see the court overturned
well if we put another two or perhaps
three justices on that's really what's
going to be has that's will happen and
that'll happen automatically in my
opinion because I am putting pro-life
and justices on the court I will say
this it will go back to the states and
the states will then make a
determination secretary Clem I I
strongly support roe v-- wade which
guarantees a constitutional right to a
woman to make the most intimate most
difficult in many cases decisions about
her health care that one can imagine how
does Trump think this happens he
appoints two justices that were
recommended to him by the Heritage
Foundation or some other harebrained
right-wing think-tank and automatically
like the snap of a finger when you get
conservative justices on the court roe
v-- wade from 40-plus years ago is
overturned I mean the guy just doesn't
understand anything and then he went
even further and exposed not only does
he not understand about the the
overturning or the changing of law
through the appointment of Supreme Court
justices he doesn't even seem to
understand much about abortion look at
this
mister trunk your reaction and
particularly on this issue of late term
partial birth well I think it's terrible
if you go with what Hillary is saying in
the ninth month you can take the baby
and rip the baby out of the womb of the
mother just prior to the birth
of the baby now you can say that that's
okay and Hillary can say that that's
okay but it's not okay with me
because based on what she's saying and
based on where she's going and where
she's been you can take the baby and rip
the baby out of the womb in the ninth
month on the final day and that's not
acceptable well that is not what happens
in these cases and using that kind of
scare rhetoric is just terribly
unfortunate unfortunate is not exactly
the word I would use it's absolutely
disgusting what is Donald Trump talking
about you can rip the baby out of a womb
the day before birth
that's called a c-section right I mean
that this is just so vile and distorted
and straight-up nonsense and I'm hopeful
especially since the polls now point to
more than half of Americans supporting
abortion being legal in most cases for
the first time since the passage of roe
v wade we've seen support for that
increase more or less steadily over the
last 40 50 years hopefully most viewers
don't fall for this nonsense but I don't
know if Trump is lying or he just
doesn't understand how things work but
vile disgusting and absolutely
reprehensible